[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Johnny is
in Cincinnati hey Johnny what's up hey
Dave not much uh qu question for you
about Public service loan forgiveness
and my current student debt situation
and mortgage
situation so I have 96 payments on this
Public service loan forgiveness
uh with the goal being
120 for the program um I kind of had
that planned for since I graduated in
2014 didn't think too much about it had
a bunch of Life Changes take place and
now I
have uh almost enough to pay off the
student loans and I'm considering paying
those off now instead of waiting for the
Public service loan forgiveness well
yeah yeah
did you say you graduated in
2014 correct so this is nine almost 10
years of just well maybe they'll do it
10 years of your
life yeah pay them off yeah not to
mention Johnny so here here's the
situation that so far
90 was it 97% of the loans that followed
the student loan forgiveness program
have not been forgiven they've only
forgiven less than
3% and so if you have a 9 97% chance
that your plan's not going to
work the reason I was son I just told
you three out of 100 don't argue with
this three out of 100 it works for you
actually think you're one of those pay
off your
loan right yeah right that's what that's
what I'm thinking what do you owe what
do you owe on it 86,000 I'd write a
check tooran I'd be free listen you
don't want to sit around and wait on
your on the government to make your life
awesome mhm because you're going to be
waiting the rest of your life and you're
going to be disappointed Yeah the secret
to happiness is low expectations lower
your expectations of what the
government's going to do for you because
it all amounts to nothing yeah 10 years
making minimum payments he could have
been done seven years ago well he's got
the money now so at today you know
either you're going to be sitting there
96 payments from now disappointed cuz
you're not one of the three out of 100
that actually gets the Forgiveness um or
you will have spent the last 10 years
Building Wealth because you got rid of
this crap by writing the check today so
the student loan forgiveness program is
a scam it's a lie anything that 97% of
the people don't get what was promised
to them is called a scam yeah it's a lie
it's a government lie okay another one
just like the Biden student loan
forgiveness was it was a lie MH he knew
it was a lie he knew the Supreme Court
was going to throw it out and he played
it at the midterms anyway just to get
people to vote for Democrats it was a
lie we told you when he did it it was a
lie I've told you this was a lie so it's
a lie and the only Reas don't fall for
another Government lie democrat or
republican you can't wait on those
morons to fix your
life yeah and the thing is you're
hearing a lot more about it lately you
know you'll see somebody pop up my
student loan got forgiven and they're
doing these it's a little popup
forgivenesses to try to keep people
hanging on the line right it's a lie
yeah when you actually look at the
statistical evidence of the number of
people who got rid of their student
loans because of the government doing
anything it's almost zero you guys less
it's almost zero like you know one of my
buddies said the other day Biden forg $9
billion yeah out of 1.7 trillion on a
plan that already existed it wasn't him
he just took credit for a plan that was
in place before he was in office typical
politic politics it's a lie yeah
God all right hope I'm through now